you won't look that there's no way
and there goes the ace oh my god
what's good everybody my name is
christopher london and today i am
here and joined with juju smith shuster
what's good
what's up boss man thanks for having me
today juju now i know
you're a big fortnite guy and i see that
nice omen laptop
that you have over there but talk to us
what what does gaming
mean to you for me uh it's i would say
it's a hobby
it's something it's also like meditation
where i just get away from the real
world and just i can play
you know virtue of my friends and create
those moments i think old man is coming
out
you know with the most convenient slim
silk laptop you know with me you know
constantly not be able to gain you know
on
on the road but now that i have this now
i can like travel the world and i can do
this and do that
i agree and that's what play to progress
is all about
let's go ahead and load up valrant oh do
you
usually play before or after games so
you have like a routine that you kind of
include gaming into
i usually play like before and after
games but you have a night game like
that which is really cool
oh yeah i know that omen laptop is nice
to travel with you know
[Music]
all right juju we gotta test our gaming
knowledge with the omen
gamer brain quiz let's hop right into
this
first question the boss dropped luke
what are you picking up the flaming
battle axe or the mysterious
wand yeah i'm gonna go with the one i
gotta go got a little camper over here
that's an easy dub
we're getting doves out here we're
getting juicy
grab your body boy we're crazy
the next question my best gaming
memories
are the beautiful single player
experiences
are amazing multiplayer moments yeah
we're also i mean at one point in my
life i was i was playing with
ninja drake and travis scott
and i was just like it was like it was a
moment you just just can't forget
and like i said like those multiplayer
moments like that's how you like create
friends and family across the world like
some of my best friends you know i met
through video games
let's go clutch up baby
[ __ ] bodies bro
i'm like that dude oh my god
um like that finally a new high score
are you clicking new game and trying to
beat it or you showing your friends
and bask in the glory got a show they
got a show okay
i'm the same way i'm the same way we got
to show you got to let the friends know
what you what your skills are looking
like what was your uh
what was your results let me see i just
got it right now
this is my first quiz every game the
muse the muse i got the rope
nice
how many kills 16 and five i'm just
different
i gotta play more of this i gotta play
more of this hey and i gotta give a
shout out to owen of this desktop
omen products hit different
now juju you have a chance to redeem
yourself here
we're going to do a fun irl target
challenge
we have some blasters we have some
targets all right juju so i'm gonna
i'll set the tone here for this round
here we go
[Music]
yes
oh you got one in there
you got two no he's gonna miss this
he's gonna miss him
there's no way you won't look her
there goes the ace oh my god
[Music]
all right so juju came back
in the irl target challenge man he
really locked in and clutched up right
there
thank you juju it's been a blast so i
appreciate it take care